Hello and welcome to this video on creating assets. We'll be walking through the process
of how you go about creating an asset from you rather than importing or duplicating ones already
there. In order to create an asset what we need to do is we need to use a specific class
called the factory and these factories come in numerous different types so do feel free to
search through the API you just type in your specific what you're looking for and you can
select the factory for that. Now when we're looking at factories and we're going to be
jumping into this in a minute the factories are going to be quite high up classes so we're going
to be playing around with the blueprint class but that's going to include anything that's below
that blueprint class but say you want to create a material for example you're going to want to go
and find a material factory and then use that one to set it up and there's an equivalent so
you can see here I'm just showing the factories which are starting with A so you can imagine
that there are a lot of them. What I'm going to do is I'm going to walk through an example
of creating a factory so that we can create an asset. Before we jump into doing this within
the engine I'd like to stress the point that our base directory we're going to be working
with is slash game. Now it appears when we're in the editor as content but it's actually when
we're working with Python it's the slash game folder which is going to be is going to be
important to us. And here we are back in the editor and as you can see if I hover over it
says all slash game and you can see that it's the game directory here that we're working with.
Okay so I am going to be setting up this script in using the the editor tools we should
be able to see it here. Now the first thing is we're going to import unreal
and I've got a blueprint name for cool asset and we are going to create this into the game
example folder. Now we want to create a blueprint so we're going to need to find a factory to work
with and so I'm going to save the reference to our our factory and of course factory
and we'll call it factory equals. So I'm going to jump into the API and I'm going to search for
blueprint factory. Okay and you can see that we have here is unreal dot blueprint factory
and so that's going to do. I'm just going to jump on there but all I'm going to need is
blueprint factory. It's got a bunch of editor properties here and this will be
relevant when we're going in mainly parent class but we don't need that for this line.
Okay so our factory equals unreal blueprint factory. We don't need to handle any parameters.
Okay so now in order to create this we're going to have to actually use something called
asset tools and if I was to look into the directory again we'll be able to find
asset tools here but this is going to have a number of elements and the main one that we
care about is the create asset because that's what we're going to need and you can see here
we're adding it the asset name package bar asset class and the factory in order to get this to
work. Okay so I am going to create my reference to the asset tool I'll do that up here asset
tools only that equals unreal dot asset tools helpers dot get underscore asset
tools. Okay so you can see that we have the get asset tools here and we got the factory here
and get rid of that just move that up so we have most of our settings set.
Now in order to create something all I need to do is type in asset tools create underscore asset
and we'll use the blueprint name that we've saved at the top and blueprint path should copy and
paste this and we go none and finally we'll provide it with the factory. Okay so here is
the moment of truth for this run. Yes it's a run so we have our example folder here
and we have a cool asset so we've created an asset. Now if we were to open that up
we would find that this is the standard blueprint of a parent class actor. Now
what if we want to create something different? Well when we're creating a blueprint class we
usually have the option to pick the parent class and that's what we can do through the
set editor properties. So if we were to go back to the unreal blueprint factory you can see that
we have the editor properties here that we can set through set and we're looking at parent
class. So if we want to type that in it would probably be something like factory dot set
underscore editor underscore property and we want to set that to parent
class and for this I am going to set this to the unreal dot player controller. Okay
fingers I'm going to delete this and fingers crossed there you go now you'll see that we've
created that and this is now of the parent class player control. Okay so I just wanted to
walk through the process of how you'd go about creating assets because that's all the main sort
of confusing part you've got to use these factories and then you've got to set the editor
properties in order to update. And that brings us to the end of the creating assets video
and I hope you find that useful.